you've probably heard about va2 it's the
new omicron cobit variant that has some
infectious disease experts worried and
the reason for that has a lot to do with
this chart it's a cdc census of the
covet variants in the u.s going back to
the beginning of the year and as you can
see from the light pink bars the
relative levels of ba2 have been on the
rise since it popped on the scene in
late january and early february so why
did ba2 become the new dominant strain
in the us and what does it mean for your
chance of getting coped or ending up in
the hospital plus does it make a
difference if you've had cobit before or
are vaccinated let's dig in
ba2's edge so far seems to be that it's
slightly more transmissible than other
versions of omicron including ba1 which
caused last winter's big surges that's
why it seems to be beating out other
versions of the virus in the rays to
infect one preliminary study estimated
that ba2 infects on average roughly 2.5
times as many people as delta that's the
covet variant that causes surges back in
mid 2021. by comparison ba1 infected
twice as many people as delta on average
that increase is worrisome because more
transmissible variants mean more
infections and that poses a bigger
threat in terms of overwhelming
healthcare systems even when you
consider that the risks of
hospitalization and death from ba2
aren't higher than with other versions
of omicron why well
it's simple math a small fraction of a
big number is still a big number
so far ba ii hasn't overwhelmed
hospitals in the u.s in fact
hospitalizations are at an all-time low
but hospitals were overwhelmed in the uk
when ba2 emerged and in the past coveted
trends there have typically predicted
what's to come on our side of the pond
ending up in the hospital also isn't the
only risk that comes with an infection
between 10 percent and 30 percent of
people may go on to develop long coved
that can manifest as brain fog extreme
fatigue and gastrointestinal problems
that last weeks or even months even
following relatively mild infections
given all that public health experts are
encouraging people to wear masks indoors
again in certain parts of the country
and to get vaccinated and boosted if
possible that brings us to the big
question does this mean we can get
re-infected if you had omicron
maybe not especially if you had it
recently it's important to remember that
antibodies naturally go down with time
and that leaves us more vulnerable to
infection you may also be fair game if
you were infected with one of the
previous variants like delta which was
prevalent longer ago or if the infection
rates in your community are really high
typically though re-infections tend to
be milder over the course of the last
two years we've had the chance to
develop individual and population level
immunity against covid and that lowers
our collective risk an unpublished study
found that ba2 reinfections can happen
but they appeared to be less common
among people who were infected with ba1
than with people who were infected with
non-omicron variants the researchers
found that out of 263 reinfections they
sequenced 47 ba2b infections happened
among people who'd had omicron before
meanwhile 140 had been among those who'd
had delta a study in the new england
journal of medicine corroborated those
results in a small group of people and
it pointed once again to the protective
role of immune system proteins called
antibodies the eight omicron patients
they tested had antibodies that could
keep ba2 out of cells plus that study
also showed that getting boosted was
important for increasing the levels of
antibodies that worked against ba2 in
people without previous omicron
infections that's similar to what
researchers found with the original
version of omicron getting vaccinated
and boosted is the best way to protect
yourself against ba2 and other current
and future variants infectious disease
experts suggest having high quality
masks like n95s and k95s on hand like
earlier in the pandemic as well as at
home tests that way you can immediately
test yourself if you start feeling
symptoms and if you test positive you
can isolate yourself to stop the chain
of infection finally keep an eye on what
the levels of infection are where you
live the higher the rates the more at
risk we all are and the more precautions
we should be taking ba2 won't be the
last variant to emerge there's already a
ba3 omicron sibling and omicron xe which
for now researchers aren't all that
worried about throughout the world the
levels of infection are still high and
that gives the virus plenty of
opportunity to mutate and that could
mean that in the future we'll continue
to see evolving guidance from health
authorities
you